- All right, Michelle.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Michelle, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Well, I was born in Anaheim, California.
At age 13, I did move to
Minnesota, Northern Minnesota.
At 18, I came back to California.
So back and forth since then
I got married then so...
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- My childhood was very,
I guess I was born in a wealthy family
so it was boring to some
but to me it was regular.
I had a very abusive childhood
as well, you know sexually.
I guess I was raised in Anaheim
until like I said, till 10 by a nanny.
I met my mom when I was nine and a half,
'cause I started my period.
So I was allowed to meet her
'cause I was growing up now.
From ages three to nine,
my grandfather and I had sexual activities
between the two of us.
Like I said, because I was homeschooled,
I didn't know that that was inappropriate.
So when I run in the
house, I'd run to his room
because it was something that felt good.
It was attention that I
was getting from someone
other than my nanny.
So I would go in there and
he never penetrated me.
It was all external but
I had a good feeling
when I was with him so I
didn't know it was a wrong,
unhealthy feeling but
to me it was all right.
That stopped when I was 9 only
because I started my period.
So then I felt too uneasy to
sit on grandpa's lap no more.
So like I said,
I didn't know that there was
other opportunities in life.
I didn't know that
people waited for things
or wanted things or needed things.
I always had everything.
My family own air Boeing airlines
so I have unlimited amount of money.
I didn't know that there was poor people.
I didn't know that there are rich people.
I just think there was us.
- [Mark] So you come
from a wealthy family?
- Yes, yeah.
I have an IRA account right now.
I'm blocked out of it due to my addiction
but I have access if I decided
to do something correct
but I'd rather be doing what I'm doing
than have to answer to or
give someone else the credit
for doing something for me
that are blatantly just
literally not humble at all.
They just do it out of greed.
See, I ended up graduating
high school when I was 16.
I didn't go to school out here.
The reason we moved to
Minnesota was because (burps).
Excuse me, I was going into junior high
and at that point because
the SATs and stuff,
they recommend you go to
school and not be homeschooled.
So my mom didn't want me to
be around any black people.
So her and her husband
took me to Minnesota.
We got up there and things--
- [Mark] Your mom is black?
- Everybody is white but me.
- So you were adopted?
- No, that's a whole different thing.
My mother tells me or told
me for many many years
that I was a product of rape.
That's what she said.
Now, supposedly her and
her husband were in Texas
and she went to a massage parlor
because they were fighting
and she doesn't remember but supposedly
or coincidentally had sex
with a gentleman of color.
So that's what I'm supposed
to be a product of.
Now, jumping ahead 41
years, I just found out
that I'm not African
American, I'm black Japanese.
My mother is German
Czechoslovakia and my father,
as I found out after he
passed away is Japanese.
I found that out due to my daughter.
My daughter is the spit
image of his daughter.
So we looked at those
coincidence and we didn't know
until that time, think
anything was possible.
My children have blue
eyes, light brown hair,
don't look nothing of
African descent at all.
So we did blood tests and
I'm actually like I said,
dark skinned Japanese.
- [Mark] So you don't have--
- I mean there's African-American in me
past his descendants, like
in my father's descendants
but he himself does
not appear to be black.
- [Mark] Your father is--
- My father is Japanese.
Yes, he's darker skinned
but he's not dark like me.
- [Mark] Okay.
- My mother...
So we assumed I was African-American.
Nothing of any type Asian descent.
- [Mark] Yeah, you certainly look
like you would be African American.
- Exactly and I think
a lot of it has to do
with perceptions.
The color of your skin
is what somebody else perceives you as.
It doesn't--
- [Mark] And what do you
perceive yourself as?
- A woman.
I mean, I don't look at color.
I don't look at color or race
because I grew up with so much...
My mother was a German Nazi
so I envy those that have the inability
to see outside of their circle.
You know, I'm very broad.
I'm not broad at all, I'm very
out and open about anything.
So I can say like...
Okay, so growing up, you go through school
and you write autobiographies
about yourself
and who you are and where
you came from and all that
and I always had to put...
My mom says like this and
then one year she told me
that my father played for Utah jazz
and his name is Roy Wilkinson.
And so one day I ran home and said,
"Mommy, I found my
daddy, I found my daddy."
'Cause I found his card
and she looked at me like I was crazy.
And she didn't remember
lying to me like that
so she didn't really know
why I was coming to see him.
or what I was gonna say to her.
So when I showed her she
started laughing at me
and I'm like, "Why are you laughing?
That's my dad."
She goes, "We'll talk later
when you grow up, Michelle."
And then that was the end of that.
I was 14 at that time.
So I felt that I was grown
up enough to hear the truth.
I never...
Like I said, till a year
ago, knew the truth.
It was always lie after lie.
Now, I don't think my mother actually knew
that Mike was my father
because of my color.
I think she also was very ignorant
and the fact that to
look any further than us,
I suppose as a sexual encounter.
She always assumed because
it was like more likely
that that was my father
than him due to color.
That was ignorant.
So you know that wasn't
because she didn't want to
or couldn't find out.
She just didn't care, I think.
- [Mark] So your father did
play for the jazz or did it not?
- No, that was a lie.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yes, that was...
I don't think my mother even realized
that that was a professional person.
I think she might've heard the name
and just threw it out to me
'cause I was asking too many questions.
So I was like, let me just
get this kid to shut up
and I'm gonna say this and
she'll go about her business
because I did.
Then like I said, I
stumbled across the card
thinking I was, Ooh! I saw daddy.
And I was slapped in the face again.
With my childhood, my
mother's family like I said,
is Germany Czechoslovakia.
We came into Boeing airlines
because a descendant of my
mother's father had flew
over the first crop duster
from Czechoslovakia.
I guess that's where it started.
I'm not sure but that's
where our relationship
with Boeing started.
Like I said, growing up I didn't need for,
want for, have anything.
I didn't wipe my own
booty till I was like nine
or 10 years old 'cause
I can't properly do it.
It can be done in a right
way or in a wrong way.
And they had no patience
in teaching you or like...
I didn't have no knowledge of...
I guess I wanna say normal
life but I was very sheltered
but I didn't know I was
sheltered until I came out.
Like I didn't think there was anything odd
about my situation because
I've been homeschooled,
I didn't see any other situations.
So where I was was totally
fine with me, I didn't know.
Now, like I said, being so sheltered,
I gained weight all my life.
I was heavy all my life.
I was always a big kid.
It didn't bother me but it
seemed to bother everybody else.
I didn't know the difference.
Like I said, when I was in
homeschool to me I was me.
There was me and a lady
named Sharon Callahan,
who was my nanny.
- [Mark] How big were you?
- I got all the way up to 439 pounds
before I lost any weight.
And I thought I was just a big person.
I was happy, I was flexible, I was mobile.
I didn't have any limitations.
I'd have no physical...
I had no health problems.
I didn't let it limit me
because it was all my life
so I gradually grew into it.
I was okay with it.
My physical abilities
were not limited by...
But I guess there was a point where...
It was just try something different.
I went back and forth.
Okay, when I was in Minnesota
I ended up going to college.
I graduated high school,
I went to college.
I graduated college, I'm an LVN.
I've worked as a CNA.
I've not worked as an LVN.
In college of course, a
lot of Caucasian people...
I say Caucasian 'cause
white is just their skin.
Like I found out Japanese is
just my race not my color.
So I got to know a lot
of them in the sports
and I come to find out
how they stay so skinny,
all that was through crystal meth.
And so at this point now,
remember I'm just coming
really into the world
and seeing things other than my family
so it's interesting to me.
I didn't know...
I didn't ever explore what it does to you.
I mean I'm in Minnesota
so up there you don't
see like there's no tents
and there's nobody like there
is out here in this situation
so to me it didn't do
nothing wrong to nobody.
Nobody lost anything.
Nobody was losing.
People were still in school.
So it was just a functional thing.
If something they did like drink alcohol
or smoke a cigarette, it
just was something they did.
And my mother had gave me
$15,000 to go buy a car.
So I went over to Grand Forks,
North Dakota to buy a car.
And I bought a car (chuckles).
In the process I ended up
running into one of my friends
and we ended up going
and buying some crystal.
From that day forward, I
did nothing but buy crystal.
My car started at $11,000
and there's this law called the lemon law.
And if it's seven days, you
can bring it back or return
or exchange for cash or a new car.
I did that six times until my
car was only valued at 2,700
because I continued to get cash
back so I can buy more dope.
Within this time span of six months
I literally sat in a
closet, smoked crystal meth,
drank sprite and ate skittles
because I had to do something.
My mouth would go like it would stop.
I couldn't open or shut it
'cause it would just get stiff
from just holding the pipe.
And I was smoking out light bulbs
so I just sat there and got high.
Days when I felt it was necessary
but I really didn't care.
I was trying to get skinny
because everybody was accepted.
I guess I kind of jumped
ahead but at 18 I got married
to a Caucasian man because of my family.
I didn't want my children to
go through what I went through.
- [Mark] Can we go back?
How much weight did you lose?
- 216 pounds.
- [Mark] In how long?
- About six months.
- [Mark] You lost 216
pounds in six months.
- Yes.
The only backlash that I had from that
was when I went to treatment,
three days after I went to treatment
I almost died of being full of bowel
because my bowels shut down.
I didn't have no more muscle.
So all my food was just
building up in my stomach
and I looked like I was
nine months pregnant.
I almost died.
They got me in like they said
if I had to wait another five, six hours,
my everything would have ruptured
and I would have died
literally full of shit.
So I don't know.
It was...
I don't know (mumbles)
weighing your options
and it worked out good for me
but it may not work out good for the next
so it's not something that I would ever do
because it's not necessarily...
I was in a very high...
At a very good place like
'cause if it happened out here,
they might not come to you fast enough.
Your life may end over
something as (mumbles).
It's not worth it.
- [Mark] So you got married?
- Yeah, I got married at 18
to a white man named Robert Self.
I did it because they wanted me to do it.
It was something I was
so used to being as if
that it really wasn't hard to do.
I did what made sure that
everything around me was okay
and everyone thought everything was okay
'cause as long as everyone
from the outside looked in
it was all right, it didn't
matter what Michelle was doing.
At the end of the years I've become...
I was depressed.
I have high anxiety
because of my situation.
I was only with him to have my kids.
My mother did not want me
or I don't believe would
have accepted my children
in any other situation
being like bastard children
or especially from a (indistinct) person.
So I did what I did.
He was cool.
He was square, he was North Carolina.
I ended up getting pregnant with my son
prior to our marriage actually.
We got married while I was pregnant
in (indistinct) falls, Minnesota.
My mom would not let me
have the baby out of wedlock
so I got married.
Now, my son was born June 25th of 1998.
I had my daughter in November 5th, 1999.
In October 31st of 2000,
I came home from a party at my college
and my sister told me that
she slept with my husband.
So I went upstairs and I
asked Robert and he said no.
I said, "You need to get
out, you lied to me."
It wasn't so much that he did
it, it was that he lied to me.
Because now I can't trust
you so I had to let him go.
It was easier than I thought it would be
'cause I really didn't want to.
The attachment was our children.
At this time, our kids are one and two.
That's when I went to the
activities that I mentioned before
with the crystal meth because
now I needed to be accepted
by somebody else and I was
like, this is obese weight
and I was not pretty to myself
so how was anyone else gonna accept me?
I have two kids.
I have everything I need financially
but that wasn't what I wanted.
So I don't know, we got divorced whatever.
He went on about his business.
I guess I could say from that point on,
I could really say, I don't know.
(mumbles) wasn't really that bad.
I went to treatment like I said.
I went to treatment after that.
I went to treatment for six months.
I got into (mumbles) house.
At that time I was getting my kids back.
My kids would come to me every weekend.
There's an exit plan
when you go to programs
and my exit plan said I was
coming back to California
because I felt sheltered out there.
Now that I had come out my marriage
and I had been in the world.
Now, it's only been what?
10 years that I've actually
been free I guess you could say
to where I'm learning
other activities can happen
like being anxious and asking
for and looking for something
and even wondering.
Those feelings I never had as a child
because I didn't have to.
It was just catered to me.
So those feelings to me were interesting.
And as I find out they're normal.
So it was a part of me that I was like mad
that I was not allowed
to be a normal person.
So now I want to be normal.
I was coming back to
California with my children.
My mother, like I said, did not raise me.
So she is envious of me having
the ability to raise my kids.
She at that time went to social services
and had my kids taken from me
because she did not want
them to come out here.
The stories she told them was true.
I didn't have suitable
housing for my children
as far as the state was concerned
but I had a place for my children.
We were gonna come back to California
and stay with my stepfather.
He had a three bedroom apartment
but the bedrooms were not adequate
because there's already two
females and a male living there.
And I was bringing two females
and two males at the time.
Or two females and a male at the time
and it wasn't suitable enough
to have legal sleeping arrangements
so my mom went in court (sniffles).
So then I guess we say instead
of (mumbles) I gave up.
(sniffles)
My mom had bought me a car.
I went to Minneapolis,
Minnesota (sniffles)
and smoked crack.
I don't know what made
me and what told me.
It wasn't something
that I had knowledge of
because my treatment program,
where to go was available.
But I said, why not?
Within two weeks of starting
to smoke my car was gone
'cause I had rented it out
and wound it out to people
that were dope dealers or whatever
and they ended up blowing my engine.
At that time my mom had been
called by the coroner's office
to come identify a body
that was found in the backseat of my car.
An hour before she was gonna leave,
I had called her to
send me some more money.
And she picked up the phone
and I called from The Salvation Army
and she picks up the phone
and I told her, "Hi, mom,"
she's like started screaming.
I'm like, "What?
It's just Michelle."
She's like, "Oh my God! You're not dead."
I'm like, "Dead?"
The whole concept of me
actually losing my life
because of this addiction wasn't reality.
And then my mom said she had been called
by the coroner's office
to come identify a body
that was found in the backseat of my car.
It should have hit me
then that I needed to stop
but it just kinda made me laugh.
Like good, I'm putting
you through hell now.
It was like that was my payback.
And so from there I just wild out.
I ended up coming back to
California because it was just...
I have a lot of self morals
and respect for myself
and for my family so I
was too close to them.
I didn't want my kids to see it.
So I came back to California.
(gasps) I don't know.
I got jobs, I had a job after job.
I'm educated I could get jobs
but it was just boring to me.
Enough wasn't happening because
I was going through so much
about losing my children.
I got my tubes tied after my daughter.
Mind you, she was born in '99
so that's supposed to
create sterilization.
I'll let you know in a minute
that that doesn't work.
I'm right now three and
a half months pregnant
and I'm 42 years old, that's crazy.
And using drugs and living in a tent
so I look at it like a why me thing
but I forget it's another chance.
I don't know, I'm kind of jumping around.
I've been to prison
seven times (sniffles).
My first, huh?
- [Mark] What for?
- It started out with drugs
because my relationships
were drug dealers.
And they always put into my head
that I don't ever say
nothing against them.
So when the cops would come it was me.
My first incarceration was 2002.
I was threatened with 13 years,
I ended up getting two years.
That was when it started.
I had another for 14 years,
I did six terms and one violation.
My most recent release from
prison was May 28th of 2019.
And most recent release
from county was April,
April 10th of 2020.
I can say now I'm actually reporting.
I'm doing things other
than my sobriety correctly.
I'm no longer running from the police
which is the first time since 2002.
So something is waking up in me.
I think it might be the
pregnancy, I'm not sure.
- [Mark] But your other arrests
were for what kind of stuff?
- [Michelle] Okay, well,
all of them were drugs.
I have now, recently my
latest ones were grand theft.
I run into stores and grab items.
I do like Louis Vuitton and Gucci
so one bag gets me grand theft
and put me in prison for three years.
- [Mark] So boosting.
- [Michelle] Yes, yeah.
- [Mark] Which is why
you're so well-dressed?
- [Michelle] Yes (giggles).
Well, treators just drop off--
- [Mark] Even though you live on skid row.
- [Michelle] Yeah, well 'cause
treators drop this stuff off
and I'm like, might as well use it and...
- [Mark] You're living in a tent--
- [Michelle] Yeah, I live in a tent
and it's not even really a tent.
It's a screened in patio for a tent.
I didn't know that when
I got it but it's large.
I accumulate stuff from the streets
like everybody else does.
Churches and people, they
help us out here bring stuff.
I've got a bed, I've got a couch,
I got everything that you would ask for,
I guess you would say, except
for normalcy in so many ways.
But then to me, this is okay.
And I don't know if that sounds right
but I'm okay right now.
I'm not satisfied but I'm okay.
- [Mark] The boosting is how
you support yourself now?
- [Michelle] Yeah, (stammers)
I've worked as a prostitute
till I was 30 but I got raped at 30
and I don't think it was worth my life.
It was a scary (mumbles) and
I was raped outside of...
See now, let me rewind but prior
to that I was getting raped
and molested through family
members and different people
but at that time I
didn't know it was wrong
so I was more submissive
and it wasn't painful.
It didn't hurt my mind
'cause it was a good feeling in the end--
- [Mark] Because of what
happened with your grandfather.
- Yeah, exactly.
And because I was never told it was wrong
because I never brought the situation up
because why talk about something
that was positive to me?
It wasn't like, Oh! Daddy
did this or grandpa did this.
It was part of my day.
Now, when I went to treatment,
I found out that all that...
Now mind you, this is 20 years later.
I find out that I was abused.
I was confused.
Abused how?
I felt good.
So I had to go through that whole thing.
Now, when I finally
accept that I was abused
which sounds crazy but I finally accept
that this person did
something wrong to me,
now he's passed away, okay?
The other people that have
done it are still around
but I forgive them on my own
recognizance, for my own self.
For me to be okay.
They say do that so you're okay.
Doesn't matter about them, it's for you.
So I did it.
I did it basically just to keep them quiet
'cause I really didn't...
Still to this day don't
feel that I was hurt.
So it's kind of, I don't know, it's funny
but because of that, when I got raped
and because I've told it
was such a horrible thing,
now when it happens, I'm just devastated.
Like, I really just feel
like a piece of trash
'cause it only happens to
people that are (indistinct)
and I put myself in that place
and wouldn't happen if I didn't do it
and so it was all about me again.
So I put through that (mumbles)
to where I willingly jumped into cars
and willingly gave myself
over for a few dollars.
Now, if I jump in the car I'm robbing him
'cause now I'm mad at them.
I've got anger 'cause they
took something from me.
I don't care if it was
that man, it was these men.
And I put them in a
category which isn't healthy
but it's reality and that's what I do.
So I'll get them for everything they got
and I don't care what the backlash is
because I feel like they did
to me, I'm doing to them.
I live with that every day
and so far I've made it.
I mean, sure things
happen but I'm still alive
and I can move forward with that.
Well, my daughter was
15 so five years ago.
I go on Facebook a lot
and one day I just decided
to look for my daughter.
And I found her on Christmas day in 2015.
And we talked on Facebook.
Now, mind you she's adopted.
They both got adopted.
So they're not supposed to talk to me.
My daughter actually got in trouble.
I feel bad to this day.
But at the time it was a blessing to me.
She got in trouble.
She shut off her page
and her mother and father grounded her.
Now, when I got out of prison in 2019,
I contacted my daughter again.
I also was looking for my son.
I come to find out that my son,
he's having a memory of
something happening to him
when he was a child that
didn't occur in my life.
It didn't occur when was with me
but they're telling him
when he was with me.
Because for whatever reason,
whoever did this to him
is once again trying
to tear us apart.
But he remembers being locked in closets
and stuff like this by some man.
The only man that was ever
in my life was my husband.
So now I'm getting
knowledge that he was abused
in his foster, in his home.
I haven't been able to find him (sniffles)
but (voice cracks) he'll be okay.
My daughter is in college.
My son supposedly has a company now.
My mother is still around
but I didn't really
say it in the beginning
but everybody is still okay
with how they are (sniffles).
They're not open-minded
and money is all that they
care about (sniffles).
So I come out here to skid
row because I can be me.
For the most part, nobody
tells you what you have to do
when you have to do it or
how much you have to be.
There's really no rules.
There's respect and
there's common knowledge
but there's no real rules
about being homeless
especially down here
'cause we get everything we want and...
So I'm here to get...
I hate money and I receive it wonderfully
but I also give it wonderfully
because having it...
I know having it doesn't make
you happy from experience?
To this day I know that the more I have,
the more miserable I am.
Unless, somebody lets
me help them with it.
Even if it's getting high, if
it's getting something to eat.
If it's burning it, I'll burn money
because it makes me so angry
that I have it for so long.
And it irritates me so
bad that people get so mad
that I spend it so freely but why not?
It comes freely, like really it does.
And so I don't know.
I've been down here since 2007 on and off,
outside of my incarcerations.
I return here when I get out.
And I just feel that I'm where I'm at
because I need to be where I'm at.
I've just realized
that just because of your
geographical situation
or your society, your
economic status in society
that's not who you are.
That's just where you are.
In a place that you're at and
who you are is who you are
from the beginning all the way to the end
as far as anything goes.
It could be a religion,
it could be the gangs
that you try to be in.
All these things,
they're all just roadmaps
of who they want you to be.
And so I've just been able to become
who I not necessarily want
to be but have become.
So I guess in a sick kinda
way you can say I'm satisfied
because I think I've
encountered a lot more things
and I've made it past a lot
more obstacles and setbacks
than a majority of people
because I'm a willing to
go backwards to go forward.
All the negativity that's
come in my life, I'm okay with
because without that I
wouldn't have got stronger.
And so today I have the strength
because of those things.
So I'm grateful not to the
person but to the experience.
And I believe that began when I was a kid
because of my ignorance in the fact
that sexual abuse was hindering.
I didn't use it as hindrance.
I used it as an advantage.
So that at age three
allowed me to become 42
with the strength that
nothing's gonna eliminate me
but myself in any sense at all.
I didn't say this at first
and I guess I totally forgot
'cause it's really...
I'm saying I put it to my hindsight
because I have terminal cancer
and that to me is just a...
It's like a piece of change in my pocket
because it's just what
I carry around with me,
it's not what I am.
I deal with it more when I'm incarcerated
because they make me do chemo.
That's where I feel like I'm dying.
When I'm out here, I feel fine
because I'm under the
influence, first of all
and secondly because I don't
have restraints or forces.
I don't do my treatment out here.
Now when I found out I was
pregnant I can't do chemo either.
My cancer is bone marrow
so what happens, I just
become really numb.
My body doesn't move how
I think it should move
because it doesn't know to move.
I'm telling myself to
but it's just kinda
basically being paralyzed.
I'm supposed to be in
a wheelchair right now.
They've given me two dates and
I've surpassed both of them.
And as funny as it seems,
my doctor said it's because I'm an addict.
Because crack cocaine allows me
to have an artificial
stimulant to be mobile.
Because when you take your hit,
your body just goes into
a supernatural place.
Like where you can just go.
Even if you don't want
to, you're gonna go.
Like you don't care what you look like,
where you are, who sees
you, you're gonna go
because that's just what it said to do.
So he told me...
This was even prior to my pregnancy.
I have to choose crack or chemo
because both of them
raise my body temperature
which if I'm doing both,
it can cause me to have a brain aneurysm
because my blood will
boil so I chose crack.
And he said, I was a fourth person
that he has had in his
caseload that has lived longer
or benefited from their
addiction of crack cocaine.
He didn't say anything
else, crack cocaine.
Because of the ability of having
you could say, a jumpstart.
Instead of having to do it yourself,
my body doesn't work as hard
because I'm taking this hit
and it's giving me energy
like a boost, like a red bull
or an energy drink will give.
It gives you artificial energy.
That's what this crack does for me.
It allows me to be mobile
without having to really work at it.
So like I said, the cancer is not me,
it's just change in my pocket.
And I feel it will be
spent sooner or later
and it'll be also taken away from me so...
And I found out about that in 2014
because my thyroid stopped.
So it's just another advantage of my life,
it's to get past another hurdle
and see how much longer I can go.
I don't think I have...
I think I have a lot longer to live.
Unfortunately, sometimes I think that
but other times it is
like, go to sleep, Michelle
and don't wake up and you'll be just fine.
But then I don't think that I will
because what else haven't I done?
Good or bad.
So, you know--
- [Mark] What do you think
is the most important lesson
you've learned?
- To say open-minded, to not be secluded
and don't close your mind off to anything
because there's so much out there
and anything that happens to you,
never let a set back hold you back.
Don't ever let a seatbelt stay on.
You have to take it off
and get out the car, right?
So take off the hindrance and walk forward
because that's giving that
situation the power over you
so you're no longer in control.
So as egotistical and as
prideful as humans are,
if we allow that one
situation to slow us down
then you're letting
that person control you.
I don't know they chose me, we wanna say
so don't let that situation control you.
Just keep going forward
'cause there's gonna be another one.
You're gonna have to get past it.
And when you stop, that's your choice.
Nobody can choose for you
and nobody can make a decision for you
unless you allow them to.
As hard as that is and as
easy as it sounds, I guess
maybe that's why it's so hard
to do because it's so easy.
- [Mark] All right, Michelle.
Well, thank you so much for
sharing your interesting story.
- And thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.